when you're feeling like
you have been forgotten
when you're feeling like people say no
it may not be no
god may be saying
it's not time
and when god says
when god says do you trust me
he don't need a lot of faith just a
little bit
and when god says it's so
it will be
thank you
jerry shepherd gets emotional on the
wendy williams show announcing that
she'll be debuting her own talk show
sherry this fall
all the tabloids and the blogs that have
been making up stories about what's
going on here you have heard it directly
from me the sheri show will premiere
this september the 54 year old tv
personality made the announcement on
tuesday where she was filling in as a
guest host i have always wanted to do a
talk show and i just came out of my
mother's womb talking now a source
echoes all that telling e.t that sherry
is overwhelmed that it's all happening
adding quote this has been her dream to
have her own show it's a big day for her
and sherry she adds that her show will
look and feel different but promises
there will be lots of laughs you're
going to have a lot of joy because that
is who i am the comedian's new daytime
talk show will take over wendy's time
slot but sherry insists she's not
replacing the 57 year old talk show host
no one can replace the queen it is
wendy's place to share her story with
you but i do want to give the queen her
flowers because wendy
had a legendary career in radio and this
show was specifically crafted for her
no one can do this format but wendy
[Applause]
of course the wendy williams show has
been without wendy all season long amid
her ongoing health struggles in a
statement to deadline the co-presidents
of debmar mercury the show's producer
and distributor said they're open to
reviving wendy's show if she's
interested following her recovery and
it's reported that the wendy williams
show will continue through the end of
its season with rotating guest hosts
including sherry we've got a lot to talk
about as for wendy who's kept a low
profile in recent months she spoke out
on instagram last week amid reports
about her mental well-being her son
kevin hunter jr asks his mom questions
during a stroll on the beach in florida
to new york and get on down the bunny
williams show
so what's going on with wendy well it's
unclear but we do know a string of celeb
hosts have been filling in the past
seven months after the show initially
delayed the season 13 premiere first it
was revealed wendy tested positive for
covid19 then it was announced that she
was struggling with health issues due to
her graves disease and her thyroid
disorder my thyroid my hyperthyroid is
attached also to graves disease
graves disease
squeezes the muscles behind your
eyeballs i feel like they're birds
swimming around my head
you know like a cartoon
wendy's rep tells et she understands why
the decision was made to put her show on
hold adding that this has been a
challenging time but she is grateful to
sheri and everybody who has supported
the show wendy williams created a unique
brand that folks are always going to
love and talk about
[Music]